because social ronan you also you won a
really good prize yeah what did you win
i won a trip to florida when i was a kid
ladies and gentlemen
look that's good tell us how you want it
i well i won it when i was a when i was
a kid and i had never entered into a
competition like that before and it was
the first day of the summer holidays
when i was i was like 9 or 10 or
something and jerry ryan who you know
was this very well-known irish dj at
home he's passed away now but he was he
was really incredible and his show was
like the top shell in the country and
shrek 2 had just come out that's how
long ago was and he was giving away this
holiday to florida and what you had to
do was you had to phone in
as one of the characters in shrek 2 and
tell jerry why you deserved the holiday
and i hadn't started properly acting yet
at that stage or anything
but dad was an actor so i was around
sort of like you know
improvisers and things like that and
man was like you should go in first just
why not we had never been on like a
proper holiday i was like oh god okay so
we got a little notepad like tiny little
notepad and we wrote down like a tiny
little script of what i was gonna say
just the short little script and i got
on and i think i was one of the first
kids on and i and i did it as the
gingerbread man and
and so then five days later he he phoned
up and
told me that we had won well you were on
the late back in ireland a couple of
weeks ago they found this clip so this
is uh this is two little clips put
together this it's your gingerbread man
yeah uh followed by which i really like
your reaction to winning so here's a
very squeaky voice here we go here we go
now sercia is 10 years of age now which
character have you chosen um i'm gonna
do the gingerbread man
hiya julie the reason why i need a
holiday is because i've
i've
i've never had a holiday before
little girl in the house are you um yes
well i've got news for you
yeah
you're going
to florida
[Applause]
when you win an oscar i want you to
react like that oh my god
i also got a blow up donkey halfway
through the week so that's what i was
like oh i'm out of it then if they've
sent me a blow-up donkey i had this like
this this donkey that went up to it and
i brought him into school and everything
i was like i haven't won the prize but
at least i got this yes um but yeah you
obviously you know you you have your
parenting rules and all that but
apparently the what is it the parenting
rules change if you go fishing
yes that's right that's right um we have
a
we ha i have a farm uh up in washington
state and on on this farm is a lake and
and it's uh
we fish a lot for bass on this lake my
son and i and i had this rule with my
old man and i have it with my son which
is when you're fishing you can swear you
can just swear when you're fishing it's
just the guys
go ahead and let loose
and so we're out fishing he catches a
fish and i'm trying to get him to take a
picture with the fish before we let it
go and it flops out of his hands and and
these bass have these little spines on
the on their back and the fin pokes them
in the hand falls in the water he starts
to cry
and he's like oh
and i said hey buddy are you all right
you all right he said oh
dad i'm about to swear
that hey you know you know the rules and
he goes that bass that bass is stupid
because well you know i think we say hey
don't say someone call someone stupid
that's bad you shouldn't say that and i
and he continues to cry
did you feel better he said
a little bit stupid stupid bass and i
was like
like
all right buddy yeah you know now's the
time get it out and he goes
that stupid bass is a [__] [__]
[Applause]
i'm like
oh all right
because tommy said now one of your
because you acted in in school but you
were in school i mean how posh is this
you've got to see a school production
and tom hiddleston's in it with eddie
redmayne
right well um yes uh
he was a great talent even then he was
at the start he was a huge star and
we were in um a school production of a
passage to india by e.m forster
there must be some really depressed
parents going to see that
a passage to they're doing a passage to
india
how long was it i have no idea very long
yeah so um all boys school they're only
halfway
eddie the great eddie redmayne the now
uh oscar winning redmayne was playing
the female lead
and uh in in the passage of india
there's a expedition to this cultural
landmark called the marabar caves by
elephant
i'm delighted to reveal that i played
the front right leg of the elephant that
eddie was running
um and four of you to make the elephant
that's right yeah yeah and he was
sitting on you he's he's sitting we're
holding a table
um with a cushion on top of it and also
tablecloth to cover our faces
because
our bodies are the elephant um
yes so that's um that sounds awful
you've just got that picture in your
head
i imagine just sitting there thinking i
haven't had a drink or at school but
carrying a some boy dresses a girl on
top of a table
and my son's playing the front leg
i can't even say that's my boy
great
front leg
with la la land in mind we are going to
focus on the early dancing career of mr
ryan gosling
now make sense of the only video you
have tonight is yeah yeah
so the dance troupe you were in can you
tell us about it because apparently
young dancers they can be quite vicious
it's a cutthroat business
and i had to get out
i i was on some
kind of a canadian star search
and uh i somehow made it to the finals
and uh my main competition were these
two
uh twins who were tap dancers and they
were dancing to phil collins uh two
hearts
and they had big heart-shaped bows and
they were just uh
they were the ones to beat so
i remember uh you know wishing them luck
and going on stage and i was getting
ready to start was dancing the everybody
dance now by cnc music factory of course
and i'm getting ready to start which is
this is how you started a winning dance
number if you want to know
get out of your hand tonight
and i look up into the into the uh just
off stage and the two twins are standing
there like the
twins from the shining
and they're just going like this
[Applause]
i just shimmied my way all the way to
to that trophy to that tiny little
trophy
because i i was going is this the same
dream i was going to say it's an all
it's an all-girl troupe but obviously
it's not you're in it right but but
you are the only boy in it yeah that was
the was that the that was the point that
was the gimmick they let me dance there
for free because i was a guy because if
you
had a guy you you would win
oh okay yeah so are you ready to see the
the
dance stylist
uh i believe you're dancing to kathy
dennis's classic touch
me
uh did the troupe have a name ryan
it was elite dance studio
and how old are you in this one
old enough to know better
enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
i wish i could say someone said here you
have to wear this
but that was my idea i thought i have a
vision for this number
and silver hammer pants
they are the silver hammer plants are i
don't think we know we gave them enough
of a shot we gave up with hammer but i
don't i think we should we should have
kept them going
no yeah right they may come back up they
make
talking about impressing uh people's
families and things and kevin you you
brought your kids back to philadelphia
yes but not for like kevin hart day you
brought them back to where you're from
yeah yeah okay
why did you bring them back well you
know uh parenting is something that i
take pride in um you know i want to make
sure that my kids understand the value
of hard work and and what the meaning
behind it should be so you know i don't
want you thinking that what we have in
in our lifestyle is how it's supposed to
be because it's not yeah there's a
there's a reality behind it so i'm gonna
take you to where dad is from so we take
a trip you know we take a real trip to
philadelphia uh and you know we land and
i said let me show you where i grew up
so you can understand in your private
jet
lessons
listen every lesson has a moment of
of disbelief just follow me for a second
i'm with you i'm with you i'm right
lesson didn't start till we got off the
property
got in the car and started driving
through in the neighborhood where i was
visiting that's where the lights were
where are you from
so we we pull up to my place and you
know i give this long speech it's like a
moment like it's like 7 a.m i got there
when nobody would be there and i'm like
look i didn't have okay look this is
this is all we this is the grass is to
see this little thing it's all the grass
we had i had to sit on the step i waited
for the bus here i walked two and a half
miles to get from here to where i had to
go to meet my mom this was not a
situation that you were comfortable in
and i get done and my kids are like
we want to live here
[Applause]
this place is a piece of [__]
i'm trying to show you what we have is
nice we just got to work for it we don't
want to go home
let us go upstairs
i literally had to stop the lesson
philadelphia
let's just go back home i'm just gonna
i'm gonna show you books from now on
no more
no i'm tragically this is based on your
life i mean this is things yeah but
i mean
loosely graham no but things like isn't
the washing machine that happened to you
what the the washing
you were very hungover oh
yeah
great tell tony foster that story
all their stories are really cool though
grail
when i was teaching
this is what this show is based on
i i went home one weekend and i was in
my 30s i was probably 33 years of age i
went home to see my
mother
and then i went back and while i was at
home my mother did my washing for me
because i was only 33.
then i went back on the
on the sunday night i got really drunk
and then i went for a curry
and then the next day i went into school
i'm going to i went into school and it
was a school in slow and it was quite a
rough school but they had a really
brilliant hearing impaired department so
there were hearing impaired kids who uh
you know struggled they were they were
really looked after in the school anyway
i was really hungover i went there and
about break time i felt really
uncomfortable i thought something's not
right you know
so i went to the toilet
and i pulled my trousers down and
some of my mother's knickers had got
i got mixed up in the washing
and i was wearing my mother's underwear
and i went oh god no oh i remember going
are you loser this is
such a low point you [__] loser
and then
the curry and the boot the curry and the
booze kicked in from the night before
so i
i i did like a fecal jackson pollock
and i started
i started going oh god not this not this
as well oh jesus so i cleaned myself up
and i pulled my mother's pants back up
and i went back into the um
classroom and i saw one of the hearing
impaired kids looking at me like this
and that's when i remembered that my i
had a microphone directly
[Laughter]
here
[Applause]
so maybe man down isn't that far-fetched
but tom you did the proper british thing
you went to an all-boys school is that
right yes yeah i did yeah were you well
behaved no actually
but then oddly for spider-man they sent
you back to school
well it was a it was a joke
they don't obviously understand my
british sarcasm i said wouldn't it be
funny if i went to an american high
school undercover to see what it would
be like to be an american high schooler
and marvel were like that's amazing
let's set it up so
six weeks later i've like with a
backpack pencil case books on my way to
the school the bronx school of science
which is a school for genius kids and
believe me everyone i am not no jesus
um and yeah so i enrolled in a high
school for three days i had like an
accent a fake name a back story and a
nice faint name ben perkins who's my
acting coach for when i was a kid but
they paired me with um a kid called arun
and i was supposed to be his brother or
something like that and arun is an
indian kid and when i came in everyone
was like
really your brother and we're like yeah
we're just distant brothers from you
know
anyway moving on
this is a science school they can figure
things out
that works that doesn't work but didn't
you but then you did
did you confide in the people
so i was sitting next this very pretty
girl in class and you have to go through
an exam
process to get into this school which
obviously i didn't do
um and she's like hey man what's your
deal how are you here
i was like well let me tell you my
secret i'm actually um
i'm actually spider-man she's like dude
you're [__] nuts bro
i'm like no seriously i'm spider-man
obviously none of my movies had come out
no one knew about it it was a big secret
so i just looked like some nutter that
showed up for three days and then
disappeared
yeah she's laughing now she's like oh i
had him right here
i have an infamous picture of me
in my 20s and i was just owning this
look i had a turtleneck i had mom jeans
on i was wearing a face i think we've
got the picture here oh no there you are
it's a strong look it's it's something
and this was this was you being serious
yeah no oh yes i think i'm cool yeah
this is full-on and are you aware that
this has now become a sort of fancy
dress outfit
like people do this they do this yeah as
a joke
seth rogan was on the show yeah and he
showed us his version here's seth rogen
as it
and actually uh some other people have
done it as well yeah check this out
hello hello hello hi what's your name uh
james james lovely james and what do you
do i'm a civil servant a civil servant
lovely in london here uh yes in london
are you from the london area uh no i
live in london but i'm originally from
um suffolk oh
oh yeah it's a suffolk massive yeah
is he mentioned in the song probably
yeah what what school did you go to um
so
i went to brandeston that was sweet yeah
i i went to primary school oh okay
did we know each other yeah
i'm not wearing my glasses james hello
yeah james yes me that's the one what
the [__]
did you do that was my best mate growing
up you're kidding me
and now you're talking to him on a
monastery
i'm not wearing my specs and he's like
oh my god oh can we not flip him and
just get him out of here
do you have a story or do you well yeah
i did but please let it be about edge
it's about it okay okay tell them tell
your story then we'll flip you and then
i'll sit with you
okay
okay cool so um yeah this is so random
mate
it's really weird um yeah when we were
younger ed used to come around to my
house and yeah like you're saying we
used to be quite good mates um and i
remember one time um
one time he's gone around for tea um and
i've forgotten to tell mum who's a
vegetarian um at that point anyway and
um so mum cooked i think the sausage and
mash for tea um and ed said you know
after the meal these are the best
sausages i've ever tasted you know where
did you get them from and mum had to lie
because she had no clue
and so yeah
16 years later i'm really sorry first
time i ever had me and also the first
time i ever watched the simpsons episode
was around your house as well yeah
that's right
okay well done we're going to flip you
now and then uh
we can be reunited backstage
[Applause]
surprise surprise
there he is
[Applause]
have a seat have a seat dude
comic book heroes and action films we
kind of assume they appeal to kind of
nerdy boys essentially yeah and you kind
of forget there are lots of nerdy women
out there
who like these films yeah yeah
everyone's got their inner nerd yeah
well you are a proper nerd aren't you
i mean when it comes to harry potter i'm
a massive massive nerd well we know that
because you posted this picture is this
your 12th or you're about 12 or 13 here
this is margot robbie look how uncool
hardback hardback harry potter
i know you're a real fan
so fancy do you know what's particularly
pathetic about this picture a couple
things really um
number one i'll let you point them out
number one it's my birthday that's how i
chose to spend my birthday oh
yay
what was in the cup uh number two i'm
drinking tea uh number three i'm wearing
glasses even though i don't need glasses
i lied to the optometrist because i
wanted to have glasses like that
now daniel i think you were where are
you at harry potter fan and i love harry
potter i just to get round to reading
the last one okay so
i just i was i had stuff to do mom
i was kidding i don't know what happened
i was just like i'll do it later and
then are you kidding me so you've read
one to six and you haven't read the
seven yeah i don't know are you actually
kidding me
couldn't bear for twins i'm not going to
be able to sleep tonight worrying about
you life is a game you mean so
i just like you it's just you keep it on
the edge i mean this is insane to me
do you know another fun fact my husband
is your thing this is fascinating
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i'll stop hijacking the show afterwards
cause i'm not here to publicize harry
potter
um my husband is in the harry potter
movies i know i was like had you told me
sooner we would have been married very
quickly but he was um an extra he was
like when he was a little kid he's like
one of the slaughtering extras you know
when draco like pushes some kids out of
the way to to see buckbeak in the third
book yeah he pushes my husband out of
the way
[Applause]
yeah i
were you ever an extra in harry potter
no no someone i had a my friend was an
extra at school
then i asked him like how did you get
into acting and he didn't tell me huh
because you posted a picture of yourself
i wanted to do that no you posted a
picture of yourself as i don't know how
old you are you're a little boy here and
uh you look like you could be
in hogwarts here you are
[Applause]
you showed me that when we were filming
i love that i feel better about my photo
now
yeah i know
people you went to school with must be
so surprised
who's a film star
daniel hello
hello hi um hi what's your name my name
is sebastian sebastian and where are you
from i'm from newcastle newcastle okay
do you live there or here uh i live in
newcastle yeah okay uh off you go with
the story sebastian well uh many moons
ago um
i actually went to school in newcastle
um and
there was a disco coming up
uh there was a really popular girl at
school
um usual side of scenario all the you
know all the guys after her
um
i sort of waited to the last moment last
couple of days um and asked the girl one
of this popular girl question if she'd
like to go with me
she said yes this was literally the day
before the disco um
lo and behold the turns out that she was
actually gonna go with somebody else
um and that other person was actually
charlie
sebastian olympia
that's the moment
[Applause]
how could this have happened to two
people
[Applause]
rachel gould
the very same yes you know who it is
wow
you know at the time you look older than
me
and did you end up marrying rachel gould
uh no not yet no okay there's still time
very last no you don't happen to have a
sword with you do you
uh you you could you could add revenge
if you want to do you want to
there you go
[Applause]
[Music]